please welcome padma
it's lakshmi lovely to meet you i'm so
happy to meet you i just i love you so
much thank you should we sit down okay
okay all right
yeah welcome home hi
this is so beautiful
i can't believe um
your crystal ball that you had which is
just who you are
your authentic self would taste the
nation
that erupted during a time when
particularly this country said please
recognize everybody
and then you premiere with this show
that is about people's cultures
did it feel like um
soothing to know you were obviously so
on the right track
i've always been interested
in knowing the different cultures of
people who live around me my neighbors
my friends
and around the world so this was just
really an extension of that and i'm
happy that you know during the height of
the pandemic it gave people
a lot of comfort and entertainment and
solace and and hopefully taught them
about their neighbors and
fellow townspeople you know these these
immigrant communities that we go to
they're nestled in different parts of
the country but they're just like us you
know they're american they they want the
same things and and we often
are afraid to walk across the street or
get to know them so that's really what
the show is about it's about getting to
know all americans and understanding
that everybody's story is interesting
and compelling you just have to tell it
the right way you just have to listen at
least they're interesting and compelling
to me i took a bet that they'd be
interesting to others as well well i'll
tell you two people who are glad they
have crystal balls hulu and bravo
um because hulu put on taste the nation
and it's just a juggernaut show
everybody's talking about it and bravo
is sure happy because they said
we actually have this other show yeah
tell me about that yeah exactly i
pitched another shirt to them and they
said well you're you know we want uh to
do a different kind of show we think
your idea is great but it's a little too
high bro for us so would you be
interested in developing this show with
us which was top chef
yeah so thank you my favorite show on
television thank you i played re-watch
seasons yeah everybody did that doing
pandemic like they watched you know i've
been on top chef now for 15 years
there's
18 seasons we're about to go film our
19th and it's it's just great i mean i'm
so happy that people still love it and
it was fun for me and i think that shows
you know we get the privilege of
what we see you do how you let us in but
you as a human being i love your
relationship with your daughter i think
you're such a good mom
i was told i could never have children
because of endometriosis and so
i savor every day with my child because
i know how lucky i am to have her i had
five surgeries i had a fallopian tube
removed i had part of my right ovary
removed so there's just basically rabbit
ears and tin foil connecting everything
together and yet those health tvs work
yeah yeah exactly i don't even know how
she
came into this earth because she's such
a miracle so you know i always knew i
wanted to be a mom i never knew i would
have so much fun i'm lucky in that i do
have a tight relationship with her i'm
very honest with her i try to remember
that every day she's growing in a
different person than she was last week
and so am i
and so i try to just come to her as she
is and figure out how i can give her
what she needs on that day or on that
week because it's different and so i
remember being in fifth grade in sixth
grade i remember being bullied i
remember having anxiety i remember
feeling like no one was gonna like me i
remember being terrified of opening my
lunch box because my mom would put some
weird indian curry leftovers you know
and everyone else was having polonies oh
i'm sure the other kids were so nice
about that yeah they're great um but now
i have a show about telling you about
all that exactly
i had a conversation with olive today
because i couldn't find my night guards
on my side table
i grind i have night guards too because
i'd grind too it's terrible
podma you just made me feel really good
about myself in my life
um because i was literally going like
you are so unsexy with the night guards
at one point i had a neck brace on a
triple threat um and not olympic style
um and
so i i couldn't find them and i and i i
said all of you know did you do
something with them and she goes don't
accuse me and i of course i not of
course i actually did find them
somewhere else and i came back into the
kitchen i said olive i want to explain
something to you
for years you took stuff and you would
damage it you would paint it you would
put it somewhere else this is what kids
do and i wasn't always like the
strictest who was like you know took
that and you know taught her a lesson i
kind of like lived through a lot of like
her messes and there was slime
everywhere and the cat you know oh yeah
there's slime everywhere it's just
everything is that carpets you know that
stuff and i'm a stain removal specialist
i'm telling you slime oh great come over
to my house because we have a few stains
on my white rug that i need help with
don't temp me i'm serious i'm serious i
just got a puppy i mean she's not a
puppy she's a rescue that's right in
november
davina exactly and davina is divine but
you know every once in a while she's
challenging and we live in manhattan
yeah so yeah yeah and then i came to her
and i said listen i found them so i just
want to say
i'm used to years of anxiety where
things go missing and they get damaged
but you've turned this incredible corner
and you're not doing that now and i'm so
proud of you so please understand it's
going to take me a minute but it's just
when you said they're not the same
person last week and neither are you i
had that very moment with my daughter
this morning and i just had a really
real talk so i really appreciate hearing
that from you because it's gonna make me
a better parent um i i was wondering uh
now that you've i've taken this motherly
advice from me you're such a goddess and
i mean i'm a single mom i was just
curious like do you have any dating
advice i never think about it
but i don't know what i'm doing out
there
i don't either is the truth i'm sorry
i'm sorry i you know i barely have have
time to date and i wish i had some
secret sauce to to give you the recipe
on that about but i really don't i think
it's very very hard you know i'm
i'm a 51 year old woman by the way it
was your birthday yesterday
thank you
i
saw this picture of you and you said
this is 51. it is one of the most
beautiful pictures i've ever seen of you
in my life thank you it was taken in my
bedroom i did my makeup myself i was
just
not feeling like putting up another
bikini picture you know i know that's
like the requisite that everyone does
and so that's how i was feeling and at
50 you are a different person like i i
just want companionship i don't want to
be married
i don't want to live with anybody i
don't need anything from anybody except
their good company and inspiration and
their friendship and you know some
nookie but like
you know what this just makes me feel
less crazy because i have been so drawn
to you and everything you're saying is
like
validating um the way i feel and i just
love you and getting to know you it
turns out i'm not crazy and i do love
you and you're everything i ever
[Applause]
[Music]
you